élection annuelle du plus grand savant
et voilà salut françois salut julie
bonjour titre regardez la fiche
c'est un grand jour aujourd'hui
l'élection annuelle du plus gros savon
de l'île aux enfants
il faut savoir beaucoup de choses pour
être élu plus que n'ont cessé pour
monsieur du snop qui rêve d'être désigné
chaque année ça c'est vrai mais je crois
que nous n'allons pas tarder à le voir
arriver que c'est un vrai prophète le
voit car il est vrai au monsieur du snob
comment allez-vous bonjour chers amis
bonjour je ne voudrais pas commettre une
indiscrétion
mais je crois que vous parlez aux
nouveaux plus grands savants de l'île
aux enfants
wren level n'a pas encore eu lieu j'ai
vous le savez quelques amis bien placés
qui m'ont affirmé que mon talent allait
être reconnu bientôt je pourrai publié
les travaux scientifiques qui ont guidé
ma vie vers cette suprême récompense le
titre de plus grand savant de l'île aux
enfants des travaux scientifiques à mais
je l'ignorais monsieur laisse non mais
dites moi
sur quoi porte t-il sur les confiseries
préféré par les fourmis rouges et les
fourmis noires arrêtez vous allez me
couper l'appétit
enfin juge donc ruiner dites moi tout ça
c'est de la plus haute importance
merci je le crois aussi et que donnent
les résultats les pires les fourmis
noires adore les caramels mous au
chocolat et les fonds dans les fourmis
rouges préfère la nougatine et les
bonbons fourrés au praliné
qu'est-ce que ça aide qu'est ce que
j'entends des caramels mous pourrait aux
fourmis rouges et de la nougatine aux
fumées noires non
ce conte être délicieux mais non mais
non mais non casimir tu n'y es pas non à
tout simplement monsieur des snobs nous
expliquer qu'il a entrepris des travaux
scientifiques très poussées afin de
devenir le plus grand savant de l'île
aux enfants le plus grand savant mais le
plus grand savant c'est moi le savons
quasiment à la laquelle épidémie alors
toi aussi casimir tu penses être le plus
grand savant de nous tous royal ans
alors je me refais fait trop de gens
importants avoirs pour perdre mon temps
avec un prétentieux
au revoir monsieur du snav au revoir
mais je ne suis pas prétentieux puisque
je suis très savants ah bon ben écoute
on va voir on va faire une petite
expérience les enfants
vous venez avec moi là je pose mon pot
mon pinceau on s'assied dans l'herbe
allez marc-andré au cna voilà vous êtes
bien installé à la spa lance savez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya l'élection annuelle
du plus grand salon de lille il ya la
fiche derrière bon eh bien figurez-vous
que casimir a la prétention d'être le
plus grand savant de l'île voir le plus
intelligent alors je pose quelques
questions dont on va voir si c'est vrai
et vous aussi chez vous et vous répondez
non mais attendez une toux mal magique
un veut pas que sur la question du
réponse entama le magic que ce serait
trop facile que générera bon vent
première question
un petit peu de calcul mental attendu à
vous faites très accessible vous
cherchez un même taux et chez vous vous
cherchez aussi celles en bois style sec
plus 12 - 4 + 9 -2 égal et gagnent
casimir n'y aurait pas droit
3 je vais demander la réponse encore une
fois casimir après c'est fini
1540 c'est ça
non alors donnez moi la réponse de jeu
vous répétez 5 + 12 - 4 police 9 -2 égal
marielle 14 7 à 5
rennes 5 c'est pas ça 712 et je vous
donne la réponse je vous donne la
réponse
peut-être que chez eux nous amis avaient
trouvé c'était une réponse des alliés
tombés hier j'en ai trouvé bon c'est une
autre question nous devrions alors une
première question 0,15 deuxième question
une question de géographie
valérie on écoute écoutez bien de
dollars pour sa prêche casimir les
enfants et où chez vous citez moi trois
villes qui se trouvent sur la scène oui
la mort vous en connaissez mais c'est à
casimir de répondre c'est casimir qui
passe son examen
alors les émirs pour être le plus grand
savant 2001 à temps alors une fois deux
fois trois fois au crac des réponses
frédéric paris parions voilà une autre
une autre et à marseille marc-andré
marseille et sur la semaine
mais désormais en temps un alors une
autre ville cherche matmar causé la
ruine alors delphine candou bordeaux non
je vous donne les réponses 1 nice non
plus sens paris rouen et puis-je pas moi
neuilly sur seine par exemple on
apprendra bon l'autre question a emmené
ses jeux sur un coussin et pour vous je
ne savais une autre question et écoute
bien casimir - une édition de science
combien une pieuvre at-elle de temps et
qu'il a noté mme fynes ses désirs qui
répondent aux rasses ça alors ça me
parle 10 jours je sais pas ça dépend des
jours
- alors anaïs anaïs à dos est d'environ
les émirs anaïs quoi qu on est à peu
près là les rites
c'est un peu plus 6 8 8
voilà ce qu'est ce qu'a dit oui une
pierre à 81 kw il ça dépend pas des
jours casimir dans la cellule de plus
c'est tout vole en écoute tu vas essayer
de rattraper à la dernière question une
question d'histoire une question très
facile à silly appelé tôt le roi soleil
casimir casimir facile alors les pot
farcie la base il s'assied l'épicé leur
et qui c'est qui c'est on lui souffle
pas bon les marc-andré oui mais je
rejoue par contre est alors allé me 16,1
le roi soleil louis saez louis xiv
je pense que nos amis se retrouvent
évidemment et ben voilà
casimir n'a répondu à aucune question
alors merci vous allez jouer votre nom 1
vous retournez à vos jeux ea dont
casimir
j'ai l'impression que la première fête
du et lettres le moins savants de l'île
aux enfants noirs
[Musique]
à françois suis content de retrouver ici
je ne vous dirais qu'un mot bravo pas de
drapeau mais pourquoi comment vous
n'êtes pas au courant
c'était aujourd'hui l'élection de
l'homme le plus savant de l'île pas vrai
ça je sais je sais mais dites-moi qui
est le vainqueur des voyous mais c'est
vous c'est moi le vainqueur
et oui c'est à cause de tout ce que vous
apprenez aux enfants du jardin et je
suis chargé de vous remettre votre père
c'est un dictionnaire pour vous rappeler
tout ce que vous savez déjà un
dictionnaire évidemment les livres de
prix c'est souvent comme ça à casimir
j'ai aussi quelque chose pour toi contre
-1 ne te réjouis pas trop vitesse et
l'objet donné à l'être le moins savants
de lille pour cet art book chambres à
air et assas et se sont un peu moqué de
toi pas vrai tueur bristow remercie
facteurs bon il nous reste juste un
petit peu de crème chantilly et alors la
chambre à air avec la crème chantilly
c'est mon dessert préféré